now as former chairman of the ERG group
of brexit territory MPS Steve Baker
Will's big influence in those circles
he's now a minister in the Northern
Ireland office and joins us now thank
you very much good morning
I feel like you were one of the few
concert remps who has been quite
difficult to predict who are you going
to back in this race and you back to
Boris Johnson back in 2019 at the last
what race you back Liz truss via Zoella
Braverman where's your vote going this
time this time around I'm very proud to
back Rishi sennak and why is that that
he's going to deliver competent capable
professional government that we can rely
on if above all what we need is
stability we need professionalism we
need to move this country forward from a
position of great difficulty and rishi's
the right guy to do it last time you
know you supported solo Braverman you
then switch your vote to Liz truss I
mean it felt a little bit like that's
kind of anyone but Rishi so what's
changed no that's not the case so when
we got down to Rishi versus Liz I felt
we had two fantastic candidates to offer
to the membership I was backing Liz
because that was the choice which Sue
Ella and the Euro Skeptics made I was
proud to backliz but realistically if
you look at the summer I didn't campaign
very hard and that was because I was
very happy with either candidate and the
truth is that it was quite a marginal
decision for me and I'm very proud to
back Rishi this time okay now everyone
is talking about Boris Johnson it feels
like he is perhaps the biggest threat to
Rishi student right now when you're
flying back from his Caribbean uh
holiday will you wait or won't you run
looked in late night talks with Rishi
sunak do you think he would be a good
prime minister second time around
there's a lot of love out there for
Boris Johnson and I respect that I mean
I've been a big fan of Boris Johnson so
many times but this isn't the time for
boris's style I mean I'm afraid the
trouble is because of the Privileges
vote Boris would be a guaranteed
disaster there's going to be a vote
before the House of Commons on this
issue of privileges whether he worked
deliberately misled the house in that
though it's guaranteed there'll be a
large number of conservatives who will
refuse as they see it to lay down their
integrity to save him and at that moment
his Premiership will collapse now the
best argument I've heard for dealing
with that is having the vote on the
first day but that relies on people
believing that other MPS think like they
do that you don't vote against a new
prime minister that isn't what will
happen 62 MPS resigned from his his
government over the pincher Affair which
in the end whatever one thinks about it
was an issue of conduct and character
well those same MPS are not now going to
go like Lambs through the division Lobby
so at that moment that there's a vote in
the House of Commons on privilege his
Premiership would collapse it's a
guaranteed nailed on failure and we
cannot allow it to happen so you think
that a sizable number of conservative
MPS would actually vote to say that he
misled one Member of Parliament rang me
on Friday to say that they would rather
lose the whip than vote for Boris
Johnson in that vote and there's why
because they think they're going to lose
their seats and they'll need to make a
living and in order to make a living
they'll need their reputations and this
is why they'd rather lose the whip than
vote for Boris in that division so I'm
sorry voters out there love him and he's
undoubtedly a wonderful man he lights
the room up when he's in the room but
unfortunately he doesn't have that you
know meticulous compliance with tedious
rules he just doesn't do it and it's
caught up with him and and I'm afraid
whatever people would like to be true we
need to just ruthlessly face the truth
as it is and the truth as it is is when
that vote comes which it will his
Premiership would implode and this
country cannot be afford to be back here
in a couple of months how would you vote
in that vote well it depends what
exactly what the vote is but I'm
committed that whoever wins this contest
I will give them absolutely all the
support I can because it's in the
National interest to do so but equally
I'm not
I'm not willing to lay down my Integrity
for Boris Johnson I'm not and um we'll
just have to see what any vote is but
really I want Rishi to win and I want
conservative members to please engage
with this reality and I know people
don't
people love Boris and there'll be people
out there leaping to social media to
call me all sorts of names under the Sun
but that's not important to me what's
important is how this country works out
and fairs if Boris is in charge his
Premiership will implode and we'll be
back here and I know look we haven't
seen the details of the vote the
privilege committee you know they
haven't done their report yet but you
can't rule out voting against him then
you I can't rule it out no but look the
truth is the details aren't really
important this isn't actually a legal
court case this is about the politics of
whether or not people think that Boris
Johnson said or when Boris Johnson said
all the rules had been complied with and
Etc whether he worked knew that actually
they hadn't been and the trouble is
there's so much evidence out there I
think the public have made their minds
up and apart from anything else it's
just too easy for his opponents the
labor party the SNP to absolutely make
hay over this and in those when in those
circumstances when everybody's inboxes
are filling up when the evidence can be
seen by everyone it's just inconceivable
that those members of parliament will
support Boris now his supporters at
Boris Johnson supporters say look he is
the guy with the Mandate he won that
election in 2019 he won all of those
seats many of them who had never voted
for the conservatives before
you've already asked the public to
swallow one unelected prime minister can
you really do the same with another I
really wish we weren't in these
circumstances I really wish we weren't
Liz truss made a mistake she went too
hard and fast she said that she's
apologized I really regret it I could
not have foreseen this would happen but
what I can now foresee is that the best
person to be prime minister of the UK is
Rishi sunak I wish we weren't in these
circumstances but it's Rishi and I I
think that he will accept that the only
set of policies we can carry through are
the ones in the manifesto and I would
expect that Rishi will choose to use
that mandate to press forward the public
don't like elections and the idea that
we should go straight into election now
really is for the birds we need to give
stability to the market sort out the
public finances post this debacle and
move on do you think Boris Johnson
should pull out of the race then I think
it would be technically in I suppose but
yeah I think it would be for the best if
Boris did something big and
statesmanlike I mean if he wants to come
back as prime minister he would need to
do it after this privileges issue is
settled I think he'd make an amazing
chairman of the party everybody knows
he's got huge character Charisma he
lights up any room he's in make him
chairman of the party he can leave the
campaign he confront this government but
he can't be what we can't do is have him
in as prime minister in circumstances
where he's bound to implode taking down
the whole government with him and we
just can't do that again we know of
course that Boris Johnson and Richie
soon like hell talks last night so far
everyone's been very tight-lipped about
what those talks actually were about I
don't suppose you've got any
intelligence for us I haven't though so
that would obviously be very big news
and at the moment until I've come on
your program I'm not on the campaign so
you know I haven't been briefed but I
have spoken to Rishi several times and
I'm confident he'll want to make sure he
really does unite the party and that's
why for example Simon [ __ ] and I on the
other end of the spectrum on brexit he
and I have written an article should be
out as we're speaking saying that we're
coming together behind Rishi and that we
both agree that the current policy on
the Northern Ireland protocol must be
continued and I think this is another
absolutely crucial Point whoever wins
this contest the only policy that can be
successfully carried through on Northern
Ireland is the one that we have
and everyone should understand that
because if if say Rishi doesn't or Penny
didn't carry through that policy the
Euro Skeptics would implode the
government there's absolutely no doubt
they've been very quiet but the Euro
Skeptics really care about this issue of
the whole UK leaving the jurisdiction of
European law and again whatever anyone
else may think that my colleagues like
friends like Bill cash and Mark Francois
and John Redwood they are not going to
tolerate any diversion any equivocation
on this point so whether it's Rishi or
Penny or Boris the same policy must be
carried forward on the Northern Ireland
protocol and I'm very pleased that
actually Simon [ __ ] and I have United
around this point quite different
politicians yeah but not that you
Simon's been very generous to me he's
recognized that I have taken some big
hits
in the apology that I gave to try and
change the negotiating Dynamic and the
friendship between us and Ireland and
it's working it's that's great but I
didn't just speak of humility I also
spoke of resolve everyone needs to
understand that the legitimate interest
of unionists is to end the jurisdiction
of EU law in Northern Ireland now that's
the hardest problem we need to solve but
we will not have devolved government in
in Northern Ireland until it's done that
means we won't be celebrating the 25th
anniversary of the Belfast Good Friday
agreement this is big stuff and everyone
involved needs to understand we can
offer both friendship humility we can
make apologies where they're needed but
in the end we've got to end the
jurisdiction of EU law in Northern
Ireland do you have you had any
assurance from Rishi sunak that he is
going to follow through on what you want
to see yes I have I've spoken to him I
think three times in the last 24 hours
and I'm absolutely not concerned that
Rishi will follow through as he said in
public during the summer campaign he
will follow through on the current
policy but again no one should be in
doubt about this if Simon [ __ ] and I
can agree that the current policy needs
to be carried forwards then the EU and I
hope they'll hear me the EU should
understand there's not going to be a
change of policy you say that if he
doesn't then the Euro Skeptics will
effectively you know well yeah and this
is me just observing I mean people
people should look at recent history and
understand that in similar circumstances
the same effect will happen we know what
a Boris Johnson government will be like
we know how members of parliament will
vote if the privilege when when the
Privileges issue comes up and we know
how eurosceptics will will respond if
they feel betrayed over the Northern
Ireland protocol we just know how they
will and if this is not an issue for me
I don't ever want to be any part of any
kind of rebellion ever again I've done
enough of that for seven years I don't
know quite a lot of it but but the point
is what I'm trying to do this morning I
have done a lot I'm afraid but what I'm
trying to reflect on here is that
irrespective of what I think those
eurosceptic colleagues who I know and
love like like brothers and sisters
they were absolutely not tolerate any
Divergence from what we've said we're
going to do and again look at the recent
past again it doesn't matter whether
people like it or not they will do what
they will do and that is they will bring
down any prime minister who doesn't
deliver on this issue now I've got to
ask listross has been the shortest
serving prime minister ever you know
we've had an entire budget jumped yeah
emergency action by the bank of England
to stop Iran on pensions mortgage costs
spiraling yes you know Labor's now
leading by over 30 points in the polls
and you backed her at the last Allegiant
election you've also served you know
four hours a government Minister you
know do you take any personal
responsibility for what we've seen over
the last few months I certainly feel
personally responsible for helping her
become Prime Minister I did some work in
the Parliamentary phase and some work
um in the phase in the country but I
really don't think I can have been
expected to foresee that she would go as
hard and as fast as she did I wanted as
I said earlier I thought they were both
fantastic candidates and I think
actually that Liz and rescue wanted this
at want and wanted the same destination
I mean I have discussed with Rishi
several times the big problem in the
public finances in the long run but um I
wanted Liz Liz's change of Direction but
I'm afraid you when you're trying to
shift a super tanker you can't fly in
like Superman and hit it at Mac 2 you
just go through the sides and punch a
hole and that's what she's done
um so yeah I do accept there is some
responsibility but equally I was not in
the treasury I didn't sit down with her
and quasi and do this budget and I
remember standing there as we all heard
him make his statement and unlike a
normal financial event it was largely
heard in silence because I would think
we all could understand this is spending
too much money and cutting too much tax
so you know I didn't foresee that
happening okay now just to finish this
is something else I have to ask you made
a few headlines this week when Christian
and Guru Murphy uh called you a
four-letter word I definitely can't
repeat on a Sunday morning uh which
they've picked up on a audio feed yeah
at channel 4 news and he's been
disciplined have been taken off air for
a week do you think that's an
appropriate action well it's really a
matter for channel four I've accepted
his apology and for me that's the end of
it and God bless him since it's a Sunday
morning God bless him to be fair to him
I was absolutely tearing strips off him
in a live interview that's because they
told me it was a pre-record down the
line and I felt his questions were poor
once and I was trying to deliberately
give him answers he couldn't use in a
pre-record but unfortunately they put me
live on air when telling me it was a
pre-record and the result was that I was
tearing strips off him live on air so
I'm not surprised that his blood was up
and I forgive him and that's the end of
it okay uh that's very good thank you
very much for being on the program there
at Stevens revealing he's going to be
backing Rishi sunak in the race to be
the next prime minister